there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hello everybody
this is episode 149 yeah and Jenny's got
a little bit of a cold she's a little
bit you have to deal with that she got
it from me I know I beat it you Dizzy's
vector I know I beat it
oh I had like swollen glands in my
throat for about three or four days and
I was waiting for it to come waiting for
it to hit me
never did kicked his ass not much sir
okay feels good yeah kinga says well you
know I got on part shark so I have that
I have that you think that shit's funny
because I'm part shark yeah got I got an
incredible immune system no I do too
actually
yeah I actually didn't think I was gonna
get it but then this morning I woke up
and I had a sore throat I feel a lot
right it's just you know just I have a
little bit of sinus headache and soar
through and stuff but that's why I'm
drinking alcohol it's like yeah alcohol
helps me yeah or at least makes you not
care that I gotta like it I got Kukulcan
and a screwdriver this is a 1970 style
show right we're gonna have a drink I
miss it's Saturday no it's wrong no it's
Friday Friday sharks don't know what day
it is I mean the party no I mean the
poor shark apart cockroaches something
down low on the evolutionary scale you
know I mean maybe like one of those
travela bites with the [ __ ] copper
based blood okay I like that like that
yeah something like that cuz yeah it's
hard to kill me with a spread disease
but I don't succumb to it like I said
you're like typhoid Tom it's part of my
defense mechanism
Dizzy's bounce off me on you yeah so
today we're doing the very famous
Richard Ramirez aka
the night stock that's right that do
share
like I said this is a 1970 style
entertainment talk-show okay if you want
to know the facts go on [ __ ]
Wikipedia man we're gonna talk about it
and we're gonna react to it okay gonna
take two hours gonna kill two hours of
your time during your commute or maybe
you're snuggled up in bed or something
you absolutely kill some of your brain
cells to know tell them but it will be
mostly factual but you know we should
probably put like a disclaimer at the
beginning we make no claims as to the
accuracy of the blood of like you know
just the ISO ngeni ngeni ngeni of course
does look real awesome research and you
know she writes true crime and
paranormal books in case you're you know
new to the show and you know I'm just
kind of long for the right eye I just I
just you know I guess you say on the
comedic relief if that's what you want
to call cockroaches it's just you know
we're old so we want to do this like
1970 style we're gonna you know lay back
and we're gonna have a few drinks we're
going to talk about it and we're gonna
discuss out yeah we're old and tired and
you know and this happened when's
YouTube this isn't television this is
YouTube yeah okay and the in the
Nightstalker case that happened when I
was you know a kid well I was 12 13
something like that
so I remember a lot of it happening this
dude I mean and I'm not saying like
serial killers in general obviously of
the scum of the earth this guy holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] man it's like this dude is
barely human I don't even want to call
him like an animal because that is an
insult to animals animals have a more
developed moral compass than this
[ __ ] douchebag did dudes a dick he
just you know he was just one of those
people that he and I think um and I'm
actually amazed that they caught him as
relatively quickly as they did because
some of these [ __ ] like wander
around for years and years like the
[ __ ] you know original nightstalker
like [ __ ] D'Angelo they didn't catch
him for years but this guy they caught
in a fairly short amount of time not
after he'd already killed like 1314
people but it was just that he was so
and I think the reason it took him that
long was because he was so
indiscriminate he didn't have a
particular victim profile he didn't have
a particular method of killing
people he just you know picked people at
random like houses at random and just
busted in there and [ __ ] yeah did
what he did you know like to ac/dc he
did yes you like desi
he was the heavy man I was a little kid
I remember when it was going on it was
local news for me because when I was a
kid I was living out in Dominguez
California which is near Carson you know
it's a suburb of LA and I remember being
on the news I remember them talking
about it all time when they'd find a new
one but they didn't call him a Night
Stalker they call it the hillside
strangler
that's a different dude I think there
might have been more than one of them
yeah cuz some of I think if I remember
correctly some of those hillside
strangler
that was Kensi inky wasn't it Bianchi
whatever his last name was I don't know
I think some of the hillside strangler
killings turned out to be night soccer
night stars yeah Ramirez yeah it was you
know house in LA area yeah he did he did
a bunch in LA and some in San Francisco
all yeah and like I said it took him a
while to like relate them to one another
because it was kind of like a spanning
like I said he didn't have any you know
like most serial killers have like a way
of doing [ __ ] it's like oh they always
step sad people are tying up or they
always like go after women with long
dark hair like Ted Bundy or something
like that but this guy men women old
kids he didn't give a [ __ ] it was just
anybody who ever happened to be in the
house that he busted into now for what I
just told you about hillside strangler
being Ramirez or some other cases that's
to memory yeah that's just a memory you
know I don't have a notes with you but
from what I remembered turned out some
of those ones that they thought that
they called hillside strangler I think
that was Ramirez it was like more than
one guy but the mo was kind of similar
in a certain way well hillside strangler
was he laid him out on it like I said I
think he'd leave them outside sometimes
yeah well me hillside strangler was
actually two guys it was Ken Bianchi
yeah cousin Angelo Angelo Bona and they
usually went after prostitutes yeah I
think we I think I mentioned them a
little bit on one of the other shows I
think about the that one that happened
in New York the the alphabet killer
because I think they were trying to
relate those two kind of cases what I
remember it as a kid I thought they had
we're confused in these cases because
they were happening at the same time
around the same place they thought it
was the same person
yeah yeah I remember that's how I
remembered it very well be I've never
seen that mentioned I think it I think
it got separated well I saw from a local
perspective yeah you know being in in
the LA area I think and I was a little
kid too so my memory may not be all that
accurate yeah this was 84 85 think how
it went is that once they caught Ramirez
and the other guy then they were able to
untangle yeah the phenomenon it was just
a general phenomenon they were finding a
bunch of dead people now and from what I
remember they would just find dead women
and said well it must have been the
hillside strangler
yeah not knowing that it was it was
multiple people that was doing it yeah I
think a hillside strangler I think they
usually did prostitutes and they usually
left them outside
Ramirez would break into people's houses
yeah and kill them in their houses I
think I recall just as [ __ ] like I said
it's just a minute home invasion
I think I remember that they found a
dead woman up near that Hollywood sign
and they thought that was the hillside
strangler yeah I don't know you're
talking but I don't think yeah I think
it turned out to be that that was
something separate yeah but you know
that's just the way it was like five
serial killers running around LA about
that time yeah and it was weird you know
I mean uh it was weird when you're a
little kid and you keep hearing about it
on the news and you remember I remember
like my babysitter being scared about it
everybody was scared yeah and she was
like 1340 I told you about Kimmy yeah I
mentioned the one year with the one he
had a crush on Kimmy I got [ __ ] I showed
you a picture Kimmy she look like a
little princess Leah yeah yeah Carrie
Fisher
the 13 year old Carrie Fisher oh and she
was her and her friends would be
watching me you know they're all the
same as age they talk about these serial
killers oh oh well he'll come and get me
you know that kind of stuff
oh yeah oh just like something out of
Halloween or the or exactly that's why
everybody was freaking out because it's
like like I said I think that it was
kind of like a case where nobody felt
safe it's like oh oh I'm not a
prosecutor I'm not the victim wrote a
file or I'm or I locked my doors at
night he did not give a single [ __ ] he
would just like bust into your house
while you're sleeping yeah but I
remember he was your husband in the head
and then he'd rape the wife and
sometimes he killed her two or sometimes
he'd leave you alive I'm ever being a
little kid
here on the local news you know and we
and a you know a deceased woman was
found as such they would mention these
things like serial serial killers that
were ground yeah like I said they
weren't sure you know and I think this
was after zodiac though I don't think
the zodiac was during my time I don't
remember that would be imagine no I
don't think so deaq killed anybody after
those as a little kid I remember
hillside strangler over and over again
they thought everybody was the hillside
strangler yeah yeah well like I said I
think that end up being this two guys
those two cousins all right so before we
get into like kind of more deeply into
the case just got a couple of shoutouts
um we're still working on the screen
printed shirts that we're gonna send out
for you guys I still have five of our
$20 Knut patrons who have not got back
to me and with their sizes yet everybody
else has so thank you very much we are
like I said we're still working on it we
got the screens we got the shirts we got
like I said that the five people that
need to get back their sizes obviously
I'm sure it's for those people yet
because I don't know what size you want
but we got all the other ones and we're
working on doing the screen we did it
one time and it kind of it didn't come
out quite right because I don't think we
exposed it long enough or something like
that so we kind of washed it off and
we're starting all over again but we
will have them sent out hopefully before
the end of the month so you know right
about the end of the monster yeah I've
been watching other guys that are doing
this you know photo screen type stuff
and there's a bunch of different methods
and I'm just gonna go exactly by the
book for the emulsion that I have the
emotion have is green and some make a
long story short but I'm gonna follow
these directions exactly first so I need
that 150 or 250 watt light bulb yeah I
gotta have this stuff printed on clear
yeah clear back no you know so I'm gonna
do it that way that way I know it work
yeah you know once I've done it a couple
times I'll get a little more creative
with it you know it is just like
anything else you just learning learning
from scratch yeah we haven't done it for
a while so you know well you know I did
mine wasn't photo emulsion
true yes the whole first time we all
yeah we squatching everybody's YouTube
fans Danny I think back in the day what
we're did
and that we're using now is what we used
to call photo screen yeah I think that's
what this is
maybe because that first attempt and I
did that little photograph a little
label of me and you it looked perfect
look like a little photograph of me and
your face it just wasn't the exposure
time wasn't enough yeah that's all no I
just forgot there's the exposure time
yeah and I gotta have a you know set
wattage and set time yeah we're not
gonna do this cuz we were watching one
guy that's just like oh I just set it
out in the Sun seconds or something like
that yeah and it kept we thought it
works but then when we were renting it
off at the Norton no I was doing more
research and if you he's doing big block
letters and real simple stuff and it's
not time sensitive we want photos and
that's gonna have grays and shading and
[ __ ] like yeah and with that that is
very time sensitive yeah I find it I'm
finding that out and now that that's
time sensitive so sometimes you can't
just do [ __ ] just can't you just pull
that you ass you gotta do it right
yeah you got a kid he moved the camera
with her but she didn't mean to here let
me see if I could read she's like hey
he's gonna sleep behind I guess she's
like crawled up back there and she's
like I'm just gonna scoot that right
over so I have some room also I want to
thank our newest patron whose name is
Tabatha hi there thank you very much
Tabitha thanks also one of our former
paced patrons Justin increased his
support during this last week so also
thank you very much yeah that's what I
want to thank you guys we're monetized
now but really you know how the way they
pay out you don't really get anything
from a lot of monetization not a lotta
size you know we'd be lucky to make a
hundred bucks a month but we do have
fans out there and really really the
great thing about patreon is that we got
some [ __ ] bad-ass patrons yeah they
come and go that's fine man you know
people lose their jobs yeah [ __ ] happens
I understand we don't expect somebody to
be a patron for life and just that's not
realistic but we always seem to have
real good patrons that I paint page we
got a lot of $20 patrons well wait
honestly it looks like I don't you know
I'm not trying to kiss anyone's ass or
anything like that but it's like all
right we have like really cool fans man
like I read a lot of you guys like
YouTube comments and stuff and I try to
answer all of them
like I can't answer all like as lengthy
as I would like to but you know some of
the like comments you guys make
specially through the movie isn't about
some of the topics that we do like that
it's just like it's really cool you guys
are like super we got a whole like
little community into the show that was
pretty red you guys are into the show
and you guys know us and you forgive us
for my failings start a role look at
that [ __ ] man like I said oh damn you
guys want to have it we do drink during
the show and that upsets some people but
you know if that upsets you glad check
out go ahead nuts up you know I mean
it's just it's gonna be a factual and
fun show you know to help you through
your day I mean you know what you guys
are doing listen to the show you're
doing housework or your work and just
trying to kill time but it's gonna be an
awesome show and you know we might lose
control some of this alcohol every now
and then but it's still a cool show one
of these days one of these days I feel
like you'll have enough of those and
you'll just start running around like
flailing your arms around like a monkey
I mean that would not go ahead that much
now I'm not that [ __ ] up that's true I
don't think I've ever seen you play this
is the first show of the day though
there's a couple times where I'll do a
couple of movie reviews yes
a movie review and I'm sure you do all
that and yeah I'm in by the time cuz
that's like three hours and then but
yeah we get to the end of that he's just
like yeah there's some people in the
comments going Tom I don't really know
you mate but you seem different this oh
okay yeah you said with Gus though your
load yeah it's Friday night we're
recording this but this is the first one
we've recorded Russ this is my first
drink of the evening you know I've only
had like a little bit yeah so I'm still
pretty the shows for the coals but you
know the show is for entertainment
purposes it is factual okay there's a
lot of fact in there but there's gonna
be also a lot of entertainment in there
that's how this goes down
you know I mean we're just putting on a
good show well hopefully yeah all right
so yeah I want to mention one thing that
was that in the show they're coming out
saying
they're coming out this is in the big
newspapers in the news they're even
having a thing in front of the Senate
telling them that yes
pilots are seeing UFOs that UFOs are
reality I had heard that that yeah yeah
they were actually admitting it day you
know I've been saying this people I've
been saying okay all those cases are
real but there isn't they're just
admitting that like people are saying
UFOs that doesn't necessarily mean
they're extraterrestrial I mean UFO just
could mean we don't know what the [ __ ]
that is
most of the vast majority are not gonna
be extraterrestrial yes some of them
just can't be explained by any other
means
some kind of extraterrestrial thing I'm
gonna say one of these days and I'm
telling you right as a as long as I have
known him he will every now and then
he'll be like looking out the cuz we
have like sliding glass doors like in
our room and sometimes you like put them
open at night so we can see the Stars
and stuff and he'll be like man I want
to see a UFO dude and he'll just like
lay there and look I said one day you
will yeah
and he's like no I don't think I'm going
to so inexperienced poltergeist
phenomena near-death experience
out-of-body experience seen that haven't
seen a poltergeist I'd love to see a
Bigfoot but I don't see it haven't seen
UFO you mean you said poltergeist okay
they haven't seen a UFO I'm [ __ ]
loaded but I haven't seen I meant I
haven't seen a Bigfoot yeah I haven't
seen a Bigfoot I don't think there is my
man it's hard for me to say I don't
think there's a Bigfoot in the United
States I think maybe there might be an
o-ring pan deck yeah yeah because there
is something there's any bigfeetz living
around here because like you would see
if there was a Bigfoot to be somewhere
out in Washington state or up in Canada
they wouldn't want to like hang out with
[ __ ] humans man they're like yeah
we're just going as far as puffins it
would have been it will it will just be
a bipedal primate that's what I mean
it's like I'm oh I'm not saying that
paranormal yeah I'm not I'm not saying I
believe in Bigfoot's but her big feet or
whatever but her big feet which which is
my preferred nomenclature but um you
know I'm not saying I believe in that
but if they did exist that would be the
least weird thing of all the like pair I
don't think that's paranormal at all
that's exact its kind of eyes you know
it's just crypto zoo
ecology which they had those yeah you
know what I mean her yesterday they
didn't believe in gorillas true they had
to find a gorilla I don't know I can't
say yeah there's a girl man I was
wanting some gorillas on YouTube than in
the suit and look at the facial
expressions on this one male gorilla and
I could I understood exactly where that
girl was coming from yeah I can read his
expressions in every second was a person
man they're not from us yeah and he's
looking at people's cell phone and he's
gone he's swipe and he goes swipe swipe
that's not a good picture yes watch it
that that was not hot yeah I like girls
grills good people they are yeah I like
him better than chimpanzees
well chimpanzee until they get older and
then they're gonna intense yeah you know
what I was at a where was I was at Busch
Gardens or Sanford zoo or something like
that and they have like a big gorilla
enclosure and I was like looking in
there through the glass and one of the
gorillas I guess it was I think it was a
male and he was kind of far back in the
in the enclosure and he very
deliberately laid down on his side and
made like a sexy paint me like one of
your french girls kind of posed and then
he just kind of likes that they're like
drink me info yeah yeah and I was just
like I died laughing as you could tell
that he was just like entertaining
himself he's like this is what the
people want to see man yeah you can tell
you can tell when you go to youtube and
look at the film from those zoos that
the mill gorillas especially like the
alpha male types that are putting on
shows oh yeah they're putting on shows
for people and they're judging the
reaction of the crowd and it's just it's
like a ritual and stuff love that they
just love themselves yeah they're like
awesome flexing their muscles that [ __ ]
and looking important they give these
important looks like they understand
that like you know these other hairless
apes come in look at them and so they're
trying to like you know put on a show
for this really cool that's gonna blow
their minds yeah [ __ ] out yeah they
definitely see themselves as
entertainers oh yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
entertain this crowd look at him they
loving me you know yeah yeah in a way
that's why I'm so conflicted because
like I love to see them but like in a
way I feel like you probably shouldn't
put him in zoos because
yeah they're really not that different
that's like locking people up when you
got to look at it this way in the big
picture because Africa is expanding
right now they're losing a lot of their
habitat the zoo is a very safe place for
them in the long run you have I mean and
I'm not saying like I don't like zoo
zoos like your old timing because I've
been to some concrete floors and [ __ ]
I've been in some old school ones where
they put like [ __ ] Tigers in this
tiny little [ __ ] with my yeah that no
that is not cool um if you know if it's
somewhere like [ __ ] Animal Kingdom or
something like that where they built
this huge like [ __ ] Serengeti kind of
[ __ ] and they just like let him run
around loose um you know obviously not
so they can eat the guess but you know
they can run around in their enclosure
and it's big and you know they can
interact with others of their respective
their species then I don't really have a
horrible problem with that because they
are taking care of theirs bets they're
on the up side of it is that in zoos
humans can't protect those species
long-term true and let's say ten
thousand years from now when we're
colonizing other planets around other
stars systems we might actually take
things like gorillas with us well I was
in some of these nude to let me talk a
new terraform planet yeah and let them
go get the gorillas a chance to live
somewhere you know I mean so well yeah I
wouldn't leave animals here no no you
like come on you guys there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on in culture especially you
know you hear about how terrible humans
are there's no other species that's try
to save other species humans are trying
to do that we're expanding and trying to
save yeah like one day humans suck sure
yeah but you know we you know there
could be a one it could be it could come
a time where humans and humans go to
other to another terraforming planet
that we created and we take all these
animals out of the zoos and repopulate
that planet with our animals yeah that'd
be awesome in a place where there was no
life before you know so you just kind of
look at it that way even though also not
like what even though all species are
temporary anyway I mean you just look at
it you know everything's temporary yeah
everything is you know species is a
very phenomenon yeah I mean and in some
ways I think that the fact that it's
temporary
it makes it more precious more
meaningful because you know you're not
here forever so we know the genome of
humans we know the genome of Apes and
gorillas we can make those in the future
if we need to but you know I mean I'm
kind of in debt Weyland industries thing
where maybe we're building better worlds
you know we might be able to go to a
flightless planet and recreate a nice I
hope so like man I'm pulling for
Humanity man it's like yeah I know there
are some like you know random humans
that suck but I think humanity as a
whole
were the only we're the only chance for
life we're the only chance because
eventually the Sun becomes a red giant
and destroys the [ __ ] planet anyway
oh yeah but eventually in its extreme
form we're the only chance so I'm into
the whole space exploration and the
whole you know what I mean colonizing
other planets and we got it well we're
the big boys now we got to be a
multi-planet species yeah you know I
mean if you we want to do this [ __ ]
right we need to be on three or four
planets and we know to take people's
planets they're not other people you
could find a lifeless planet and bring
like yeah I would hope that we would not
get their planet that had its funding
like that [ __ ] you this is our planet
universe is huge man is like there's a
lot out there we can do it there's a lot
of raw material out there we could do
what we learn mean it's a big universe
like [ __ ] on someone else split just
leave them alone man it's like you can
go find your own place hell I've been
drinking on a universal level talk about
spacing again some people suck exhibit a
Exhibit A yeah these are the ones we're
trying to weed out a gene pool yeah yeah
yeah all right so let's start talking
about the take it down to a lower level
this is gonna be you know nasty but this
is what we do this is part of this
[ __ ] job yes all right yeah all right
so as I said let's let's kind of start
from the
beginning now Richard Ramirez it was
actually born ricardo Leyva Munoz
Ramirez now his parents he was born in
the United States he was born in El Paso
Texas
his parents were Mexican immigrants his
dad had been a cop in Mexico but I guess
when he came here he took like kind of a
manual labor job like on a rail Rick
railway now his mom and this will be
important later his mom worked in a boot
factory and she worked with a lot of
chemicals like treating the leather and
stuff like that
now Richard was the youngest of their
five children all of their four previous
children had various birth defects
because of the chemicals yeah um you
know so there was that whole thing now
the strange thing is that when Richard
Ramirez was born his mom actually still
worked at the boot factory up until she
was five months pregnant with him but
she had to quit because the chemicals at
the plant were causing her to you know
throw up and pass out and I heard like I
watched this one documentary about it
said the doctors were telling her oh
well you know all these chemicals are
happening and there might be something
really wrong with the kid and like your
body is trying to expel it so we would
not recommend being around these all
these industrial chemicals because this
is [ __ ] your kid up but she so she
quit when she was five months pregnant
now interestingly like I said even
though his four other siblings and now
one of his siblings had like pretty
drastic like birth defects but Richard
Ramirez when he was born he seemed
normal
and when he was a kid all of his friends
his family and stuff said he would this
he was the sweetest kid in the world he
was like a little angel they said wish
super bizarre cuz usually you know
serial killers they're like oh they
started killing cats and [ __ ] like that
when they were kid but not so much with
him hmm um he didn't start getting
[ __ ] up until he was like in his
teenage years but they said when he was
a kid that he was like a really nice kid
and you know totally empathetic and
everything like that
now some sources have said that
his dad was abusive but I don't know
like yeah he would beat the kids with a
belt he would do this kind of stuff and
he was very strict he was you know a
strict disciplinarian and stuff but I
don't know because I know like some
people like spanked their kids and stuff
and it's not that won't make you serious
that's what I mean I I don't think that
that had anything to do with it now
another interesting thing about Richard
Ramirez though and this is something you
see in a lot of serial killer cases
well one he was an epileptic they didn't
know that until he was in his teenage
years to eat a couple of head injuries
hmm that's something that turns up in a
lot of serial killers backgrounds head
injuries that gives you kind of like a
lack of impulse control that definitely
seemed to be the case here yeah so as I
said he didn't have like a messed-up
childhood or nothing like that it was
that you know they were kind of poor you
know their working class and stuff but
their parents were you know worked very
hard and they tried to like provide for
their family they do you know the the
kid his brother who I think was one of
his brothers who had the birth defects I
mean they paid for like all these
operations and stuff for him to get
better it was some kind of like
orthopedic I guess he had like club feet
or something I'm not sure what is about
feet it was like you know his like um it
was some kind of issue with like his
feet being like turned in or like
deformed or something so they had like a
bunch of you know they gave him a bunch
of operations for that which we're very
expensive so you know obviously they
this was a loving family so it wasn't
like super messed up so about just a
regular California there's just a
regular well no taxes it was text okay
they lived in Texas okay so just a
regular working-class Texas family
nothing unusual yeah there was really
not much unusual at all okay like I said
dad was very strict they were a rather
strict Catholics yeah but by all
accounts their mother was like a very
loving person it's like you know she
doted on the children they all loved her
they all loved each other you know all
the siblings and stuff they all got
along they protected one another just
like a normal
family you know nothing super weird so
but then later on as kind of Richard
Ramirez gets into his gets into school
he's like in fifth grade and as I said
they finally realized that he had
epilepsy now he had grand mal seizures
and the doctors were like well and this
is something that happens with children
that have epilepsy sometimes it's like
oh well later on he might grow out of it
and he eventually did um but you know he
was doing okay up until he was about 13
years old but then when he got into like
junior high about seventh grade then
things kind of started to take a turn
for the worse now he was into football
like he was into sports and he was on
the football team I think he was a
quarterback but he eventually ended up
getting thrown off the team because of
his epilepsy because sometimes he would
have seizures like in the middle of a
game and the coach was like you know
they they couldn't rely on him or
whatever so so he had a chance for
greatness yeah greatness was denied yeah
so maybe that maybe that might Bend if
like it feels like this is kind of like
one of the defining right well you know
one of the criminal psychologists that I
was listening to that was talking about
him was saying you know a lot of the
kind of not imprinting but a lot of that
you're kind of like you know significant
psychological development happens in
your early teenage years so something
have really [ __ ] up or something that
really affects you it doesn't you have
to be super [ __ ] up but if it really
affects you a lot in that time period
then that could kind of be like a
turning point that sort of term you know
sends you down a different path which
indeed seems to be that the seem to the
speed that seems to be the case here I
have cold you guys yeah we're lucky that
we're getting an episode tonight I don't
feel that bad but yeah so so he got
dropped from the team and by all
accounts like his sister Ruth like said
that really really upset him and like it
really affected him a lot
now at around this
time and again this was a very formative
experience now this is super [ __ ] up
now what I said his family was normal
I'm just talking about his little
nuclear family I'm not talking about his
extended family because those people
were [ __ ] crazy cuz listen to this
[ __ ]
so Richard Ramirez is about 12 or 13
years old and he starts hanging out with
his cousin Mike
now his cousin Mike had been a green
beret in Vietnam he had done toured two
tours of duty you know got all kind of
you know medals for valor and stuff like
that so he comes back and he starts
hanging out with Richard and showing him
this shoebox full of photographs that he
has taken of all the random rapes and
murders that he has perpetrated against
Vietnamese women and he was like super
proud of it like he would not Vietnamese
women to trees and rape them and then
cut their heads off and then he would
pose with the heads and like he just had
like a box full of pictures of this
stuff and he would just like talk to
Richard about it like it was the coolest
thing ever
now as this box ever been found well as
far as I know it's like every source
that I've seen of this well because Mike
was later I'll I'll get to that okay
Mike got in trouble later and got some
later this yeah yeah yes so he this so
we're in Vietnam was this do they do
they know oh I don't know okay but I
mean that was a parent I mean I've heard
of like a lot of that kind of [ __ ] going
on over there like you're kind of random
every now and then you get this [ __ ]
dude that just kind of goes off and this
seems like one of those individuals and
Mike's wife had also complained that he
had been very very different when he
came back from there like he was all
messed up so um yeah so yeah his wife
was saying that like pretty much mike
comes back from the war it's like all he
wanted to do was smoke pot and hang out
with richard he was younger obviously
you know and he's just like talking
about all the [ __ ] he [ __ ] over
there and like all the people he killed
and all this other kind of [ __ ] and like
he was talking about it like it was all
badass and everything now on this one
particular day him and his wife were
having a fight while Richard is in the
house and Mike pulls out a 38 which he
kept in the refrigerator because he told
the Richard I like to keep my gun cool
what the [ __ ] yeah he kept 38 he pulls
it out of the fridge and shoots his wife
in the face okay in front of Richard he
likes to keep it cool killed her I have
no idea why he'll so he won't perfect we
got a refrigerator I don't know yeah
he's a crazy person crazy he's a crazy
person so yeah he murdered his wife in
front of Richard I mean Richard had that
he's blood splattered on his face and
everything hmm
so you know Mike goes to trial for the
murder obviously as you would now
because he had such you know all the
medals from the war and he was like a
war hero and everything like that also
kind of crazy um they actually sent him
to a mental hospital so he was in a
mental hospital for a few years okay now
so just
he had PTSD he was a nutcase killed his
own wife during an argument yeah Richard
sees it makes a big impression on him
yeah he had all those medals well Mike
was like his hero yeah and he kind of
got away with it he would so maybe this
made some kind of maybe this became a
kind of like a role model for him oh
definitely yeah he definitely was yeah
so he's learning an early age that
sometimes when a woman pisses you off
you might want to put a bullet in her
yeah you just yet well yeah that's
exactly that's exactly how it seems
that's what it sounds like cuz I mean
you have to think at this time Richard
Ramirez and I'm like I said I'm not I
don't feel sorry for the dude or nothing
like that because you know you got
choices man yeah but like he was only a
kid at this Roy and Mike was much older
and he seemed super cool he'd been to
the war he did all this black
quote-unquote badass [ __ ] he was all
tough and everything and so he was like
he really looked up to him and the fact
that he just like shot this you know
just like oh yeah just shot her right in
the face like in front of him that
seemed to really really make a big
impression yeah for those of you new to
the show I'm
I'm an Army veteran you know 101st
Airborne Division first in the 506 first
and three to seventh I was in recom
platoons shooting a woman in the face is
not a tough thing to do it's not uh no
that's a pussy-ass thing to do okay you
ask me it is all right there's no
argument yeah so Ramirez is getting a
bad example of what badass is all about
exactly now somebody's trying to kill
you you're trying to defend one of your
teammates yeah you do what you gotta do
okay if it's a woman that's attacking
yeah you do that but no you're in a
domestic dispute you put a bullet in
your wife
no you're [ __ ] just because she's mad
at you and she and she's and she's
understandably mad at you because you're
acting like a crazy person
yeah so she has every right to call you
out that's not even right if you asked
me that's not even PTSD nobody I seemed
like a few just a dick well exactly
because you know [ __ ] I have PTSD I
know a lot of other guys have had PTSD
you know I'm disabled veteran PTSD does
not manifest itself like that
no that's just business unless you're
already like that to start with yeah you
know I mean I think you kind of have to
have some of that [ __ ] they call toxic
masculinity toxic masculinity most
badasses don't have toxic toxic
basketball because you don't need it no
most badasses are too strong that
they're strong toxic masculinity is the
sign of a weak man well yeah because if
you have to go around telling people
what a badass you are
and end up women to prove your dominance
than your [ __ ] [ __ ] no no you're
really a badass you don't have to tell
any but sure everyone just knows a true
alpha male just basks in the love that
he has given that's usually how it
actually goes down you never very click
it when you meet a real badass and a lot
of time you know you've met some real
badasses that's a real alpha males
everybody loves them yeah they're not
dicks everybody loves them and they
don't have to tell you like I said yeah
no you just know this is a cool batter
they don't have to be like hey look what
a badass I am you know I don't I mean
that's like right they're not like that
they're warrior Catholic insecurity [ __ ]
like warrior kings and everyone
gravitates to them and their protection
and they protect you and you protect
them it's a it's a synergy yeah yeah
that's all so as I said you know Ramirez
he's at a very impressionable age I
suppose he's hanging out with this his
cousin who you know he looked up to
obviously and obviously not the best
role model because he was a [ __ ]
crazy person so Mike is put into a
mental hospital so after that happened
um Richard Ramirez I guess he just
decided that was gonna be the way he was
gonna I said I want to be able like Mike
or I want to be like that yeah so he had
actually been doing okay in school
before that like you know just average
or you know maybe a little bit better
than average but after that he just said
[ __ ] it I'm not interested anymore he
just started like smoking pot he's only
like 13 at this point and all this other
kind of [ __ ] then he goes to LA like I
said he was from El Paso Texas he goes
to LA and he starts living with his
brother Ruben for a little while now his
brother Ruben was also a criminal being
he was like a burglar also a heroin
addict so that was again really no good
role models yeah you know other than
like his mom and dad who I guess were
probably pretty decent role models but
when he got like into his early teen
years it just by the wrong getting
influenced by this is like the textbook
definition of like falling in with a bad
crowd yeah this is like falling in with
the worst crowd that you could possibly
fall in with so he's living with Ruben
that's like all they wanted to do is
like they're just breaking into houses
and stealing [ __ ] and fencing [ __ ] so
they can like buy their next you know
buy the drugs or whatever so eventually
he goes back to El El Paso and of course
I mean understandably his dad is like
what the [ __ ] is going on with you guys
it's like he just can't believe you know
what what wastrels his children have
become so
it just makes him like super sad and
then they start having like all these
conflicts and stuff like you know as you
would because his dad wanted better for
him obviously and it didn't really work
out um you know Richard kind of saw his
dad is like oh like a lot of teenage
boys do it's like you can't tell me what
to do blue blue so it was kind of that
whole kind of thing going on
so Richard eventually moved out and he
moved in with his sister Ruth and her
husband now again this in a way I don't
want to say this poor kid because it's
[ __ ] Richard from Paris and nobody
wants to feel sorry for Richard Maris
but at this point he was only a teenager
they always start out as children they
do they always start out as children and
you know to me in putting children at
the gate door used in this way
eventually they become monsters yeah
it's just it's sad because children yeah
because it's like there's so many points
where I'm not some baby what is in my
life too well yeah there's so many
points when it could have gone a
different way
mmm you know what I'm saying maybe he
was messed up from the beginning because
of you know birth defects or whatever
because of his mama Liz you know those
industrial chemicals that she had to
work with but I feel like he didn't
really start going downhill until he was
in his teenage years and had all of
these negative male role models around
him that were like kind of steering him
down this particular path so he goes to
move it so he goes to live with his
sister Ruth and her husband whose name
was Roberto Roberto was also a dirtbag
um he was a peeping tom yeah so he
started to be selectable possession walk
around looking in people a lot of money
in peeping - yeah a lot of money in that
yeah we're gonna make the big money yeah
so what do you like - I like to be a
peeping tom so yeah so him and his
brother-in-law now like I said this is
still a teenage kid are now going around
looking for the choices houses in the
neighbor
where they can like unlike me naked
women and self bags I know okay so they
can't they can't create their own wealth
they steal other people's welfare yes
sell it for pennies on the dollar
yeah they can't get their own women they
got to sneak a peek sit other other
people yeah okay so that's what you deal
with here that's that's a good point to
make it's like this is somebody that
can't yeah they don't have any
accomplishments in there oh it's
actually like a job somebody yes is it
that's exactly what they're doing so at
this stage like his sister Ruth
obviously is horrified by all of this
going on said that he started you know
Richard they had been very close family
when they were kids and stuff like that
she said he started acting very ways you
know you walk in horizons dirty it's
like he was always on drugs he never
slept sometimes he wouldn't sleep in the
house like he would go down the street
and sleep in the [ __ ] cemetery and
[ __ ] like that he was doing [ __ ] like
that he also started taking he was
smoking pot at this point I think he
started smoking pot when it was like 10
or something like that so you know yeah
also started taking like LSD other
hallucinogens and all that other kind of
[ __ ] it was around this time that he
also started getting into you know
there's anything wrong with it not well
yeah it's just in this case judging
about yeah that drug about pot now iced
tea and stuff it's like look I know a
lot of people yeah a lot of people that
are a lot of pot heads a lot of people
who are know like LSD actually that's
that thing none of them were serial
killers I know I mean you know I've
known cool kook freaks just as yes they
can control their [ __ ] because honestly
like you'd probably be horrified but
like a lot of people do drugs
a lot of people Billy Idol was a coke
freak love that guy bad [ __ ] that I
love it and 99% well it's just like
everything else it's just and that's why
I kind of like can you afford that habit
no I'm saying he could so yeah well and
that's why I night and I think I
mentioned this on our Norwegian death
metal show it's like I don't I don't
like to like cast aspersions on you know
black metal or on drugs or anything like
that because 99
point nine nine nine percent of the
people that listen to black metal or or
take LSD or whatever not doing are just
normal people you know what I mean
they're not serial killers it just seems
like some kind of thing where if
somebody's already a serial killer then
they gotta like backtrack and say oh
well they did this done the other thing
and there are some that contributed and
there's a certain kind of personality
that just can't do drugs they can't do
drugs they can't do alcohol they can't
do anything anything they do they do it
to extreme yes definitely a personality
yeah average person can basically kind
of pretty much do anything is well you
can take it or leave it
yeah you can do anything in moderation
and usually get away with it I mean
there is an addictive personality type
exactly and I will definitely say serial
killers and in this type of yeah tense
criminal are addictive personality yes
very much
and and I think that that's kind of like
all of a package because it's kind of
like they're addicted to the adrenaline
rush of killing people or raping people
or whatever is they're doing so it
almost seems like a similar kind of
thing where they also get a to the
alcohol or drugs yeah that whereas most
people that drank or most people that
you know do coke or LSD or whatever it's
like you don't do it all the time you
just do it like and walk away from it
yeah it's like you just take it or leave
it you just do it when you're out like
heaven there's a few imamat never [ __ ]
with I would never [ __ ] with heroin I
mean I've heard people they start
[ __ ] with that they just become
worthless they can't walk away with it
weight from it you know I mean but yeah
that's one I would never but I've been
in hospitals and it could be Demerol you
know I mean it and it is kind of
addictive they take it away from you and
you're like I wish I had my pain
medicine but you know a few days later
you forget all about it
yeah and so there is some mercy he's
getting big bigger grip on you than
others yeah you know cocaine's one of
them that can get a pretty tight grip on
you that never got me yeah you know I
mean but there there's a lot of people
that are like me that can do a little
bit of everything in their life well we
know a lot of people you know a lot
anywhere like that and usually like
every now and then like do there's a
good time you just do it and then like
and you just like forget all about it
yeah forget all about I'm like I said I
think 99.9% it's just it's just that
small percentage of weak people that
really fall in that have that kind of
personality type that they can't just
although I'm gonna say weak people I
know a dentist that got hooked on
cocaine like [ __ ] crazy yeah I'm not
gonna say we I don't mean any judgement
yeah do you know what happened to him
he had enough money to afford it on a
regular basis and when that happens you
can get sucked down that down rabbit
hole well yeah because you're like well
you know what I know yeah I'll buy some
more that below you know maybe it's my
goal and actually have money because if
you don't have money they're like well I
can't afford drugs i'ma try it myself
out no and yeah next thing you know he's
fence it off and selling everything out
of his damn house to get blow and cook
and coke [ __ ] you know I mean because
blow comes with women every every time
you there's a blow dynamic there's also
a coke or dynamic and I think it's
equally CoCoRaHS can smell it yes shark
with blood and exactly it's like they
can smell what exactly and they come
hovering over like a V into a flower and
a [ __ ] [ __ ] can look
handsome as [ __ ] when blows involved
these coke [ __ ] just coming out of the
woodwork you don't talk about going
you're them I get it increases a man's
look into it increases of man's charisma
in the eyes of a coke or well I don't
know about charisma they're just like
he's just saying the guy's got coke yeah
he's got coke that's pretty much the
only what I'm saying that cuz he gets
real handsome yeah super super handsome
yeah all right so yeah so he's doing LSD
and pot and stuff and like I said no
judgment people do that hey yeah so you
know I'm just saying [ __ ] happens
[ __ ] happens now also around this time
he starts getting into Satan man
yeah say yeah ain't gonna happen
sometimes well back in the 70s in the
yeah back in the seventies Satan what
happened remember like we should
like a read back when Satan had mystique
yeah you look at the [ __ ] now just play
it out hard to be a saint yes like Satan
my heart is hard to be a Satanist in a
world filled with this well that's why
the Satanists now are actually Danzig's
holding his head low right back carrying
his cat litter carrying his Katy litter
out to his car
poor Glenn I'd say why didn't we pick
him in like what he says buy a cat
litter people got a bike cap I was just
that one photo I like man I do too yeah
that's you know people he's kind of a
douche but you know like people pick out
of his stuff Magette I'm a judge Glenn
just buy his music I was why I was
watching Glenn just back in back in
Boston place called uh there's called
Avalon either Avalon or access I forgot
the name dear family I'm [ __ ] at the
front over at the front of the crowd
next to me are some Japanese school
girls they're still working as a 1950
[ __ ] I mean cuz well lately uniforms
yeah like school uniforms but they're
the new college students freshman
college students and I'm [ __ ] jamming
out the [ __ ] dancing Type O Negative
opened up for him this is a good show
I liked it yeah it [ __ ] glanced up
their [ __ ] singing man I grabbed him
by his boot all right a tannic energy
went up my clan [ __ ] look down keep
keep my foot it's like why you like
don't grab knighted yes I would do that
see I'm like what does now he was in he
was [ __ ] into the whole shuttle aspect
he's roided-out and everything it's a
movie you know that was that was Glenn
and his [ __ ] height yeah yeah it was
good show love it is it it sounded like
I can all I can think of now is that
picture with the kitty litter well it
just because so many people have videos
of him being knocked out by a big old
fine I'm seeing it fat [ __ ] you
don't mean but you know anybody can
knock out anybody although I admit
anybody cannot so many you steep
somebody and hit him in a sweet spot you
can knock out anybody but you know now I
respect that yeah you know for what he
does yet and I like the
you know right so mammy
yeah are so ballin if you want to be
there yes Alan yeah you want to be all
pedantic about it yeah yeah so again
Satan is mm-hmm so all right so when uh
Ramirez is in high school he gets a job
at a hotel which means they give him
access to the master key which is not a
good thing because he got into like the
whole peeping tom thing so what he
starts to do is he starts like opening
the women's you know hotel rooms and
like watching them like while they're
you know look at their the one doesn't
[ __ ] now there is one case in the and
the people that this that where the
victims of this are not named but what
he did was he opened up this one woman's
room there's this couple that was
staying at the hotel that he worked at
he used his key he opened up the room
and then the woman was in there by
herself he sneaks up on her he surprises
her tied her up and started to rape her
her husband comes into the room and
beats the ever-loving [ __ ] out of him as
you should like a man does now like they
turned him over to the police
now sadly the couple were from out of
town and they didn't press charges
because they didn't want to have to come
back to town like testify and [ __ ] like
that I could have [ __ ] stopped a lot
of [ __ ] and well he was only 15 years
old at the time he was a you know he was
a juvenile so they were just like we
don't want to like be involved in that
kind of [ __ ] I don't know if he
completed the rape or if he was like in
the process of doing the rape when the
husband came in and started beating the
crap out of him um but yeah like I said
there were somebody turning points where
somebody could have like just beat this
[ __ ] to death and the whole
human race would have been better off
but you know he's you know hindsight's
20/20 like I said it was only a
fifteen-year-old kid no one wants to
beat a fifteen-year-old kid to death for
Christ's sake yeah you got different
people seating snippets of this guy at
different times and it's not writing it
all together so for you exactly he's
just some [ __ ] a little weak 15 year
old jerk-off [ __ ] do this stupid [ __ ]
that's what I mean it's like nobody knew
seriously right so it's like you know
like I said hindsight is 20/20 but you
can't like go try a lot of them out
there doing that kind of stuff - yeah
and and again this is something you know
teenage boys are really the stupidest
you know animals on the planet so the
fact that a teenage boy did something
stupid it's like ooh newsflash they all
do something stupid yeah it's like how
do you know which one's gonna later turn
out to be a serial killer because they
all do stupid serial killer [ __ ] when
they're that age yeah and you know and
Ramirez brothers Maris was not a
physically imposing guy yeah I mean he
was when he was grown he was kind of
tall but he was a thin towel
mm-hmm why are we gonna match the weedy
fella imagine it 15 News pretty much
[ __ ] yeah yeah price slapped around
pretty good well you're a grown man it's
gonna beat the crap out of him which it
makes me happy it's only a
fifteen-year-old kid at the time and I
can't remember I can remember him as a
grown man and you know you could break
him you know he wasn't a big dude even
then he had like some weird I don't know
he was famous he had a [ __ ] intense
face he look like Mick Jagger a bit like
an evil Mick Jagger but no he hit you
yeah get an intense face but it was just
his face in his words yeah yeah I mean
he's kind of laughable though - well I
find that because the whole Satanism
thing and I guess he did that too like
freak out the squares or whatever but
like I said on the black metal show but
to me it just seems very try hard and it
just seems looser boo
hail Satan I'm like oh yeah and it was a
it was like back in the day
bad a day maybe that would impress some
we've been back in the day I was just
kind of like just stop it stop it there
was a certain mystique I guess you could
say I mean it's it's trying are he
wouldn't have worked with me out of foam
that [ __ ] up I wish someone yeah 13 14
people would still be alive but yeah so
okay so at this point like as I said
Richards only 15 years old he goes see
he's only a juvenile he goes to the
judge he's like oh well you know we were
having consensual
sex and then she decided she didn't want
to involve one so they kind of like went
easy on him because he was only a
teenager now at this point it's 1977 now
crazy cousin Mike the one who shot his
wife in the face after coming back from
Vietnam gets out of the mental hospital
he wasn't in there very long
yeah killed her he did and got out yep
oh good well they were like oh it's a
wonder how many years we talked about
[ __ ] not that many yeah not that many so
he gets out in 1977 and starts hanging
out with Richard Ramirez again and by
this stage because you know Ramirez has
been hanging out with his [ __ ]
brother-in-law who's kind of a peeping
tom and a cat burglar and all that other
kind of [ __ ] so he's learned all kind of
stuff from that this whole thing about
shooting your wife in the face and then
getting out a few years later that would
never happen today mm-hmm we're talking
about 70s yeah no not today
I was kind of wondering about that
because it seems like well [ __ ] even
into the 80s maybe because I'm just a
girl so I'm kind of more sensitive this
kind of [ __ ] but even into the 80s it
was just kind of like you know you shoot
your wife they're billing well she was
nothing off you know and like that they
would still put you in prison but it
wouldn't be as big a deal you know what
I mean I feel like it wasn't as big well
there was like even movies in the 60s
and 70s this like dudes were like
smacking women around and everybody's
like oh [ __ ] I don't remember much
about that you know I mean I was around
during that time but I see that yeah so
I don't have an opinion on it but I tell
you what today you shoot your wife in
the face they say you're crazy you're
never coming out of it now out of that
hospital ever well you shouldn't they're
gonna say yeah you're you're crazy
you're not responsible but you're gonna
be here in this hospital for the
religion yeah we're gonna put you in
here on dope you up so you're are you
injured to anyone else right that's
exactly what they would do which good
yeah rightly so like I said this
[ __ ] here about like oh he shot his
wife in the face always crazy blah blah
blah okay
he's clearly still crazy clearly you're
crazy gonna pull the trigger on your
wife's face then you're gonna be crazy
forever
that's what I mean I don't know if you
can fix that kind of noisy no you know
what I mean how things are what's the
time I'm just saying what's the time
it's bright Howie it's time for a break
we haven't even started talking about
the murders yet we're gonna talk about
him in the second half all right all
right so don't we're gonna take a break
when we come back is worse we're still
talking about like we're married yet
he's not even 20 years old yet oh yeah
yeah so when we come back we're gonna
talk about all of the iconic murders
have you got caught all that other kind
of stuff so we're gonna take a break we
will be back in just a minute
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest
unsolved murders of the 20th century
volume 2 includes cases spanning the
years from 1960 through 1979 featuring
such infamous crimes as the triple
homicide at Lake Bodom the family
Massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format oh my goodness
right so tired at all the time
this is like it fits baby cookie exactly
Wow I thought really bad I know that
video game is very very loud look at
where Beijing went to because daddy was
vacuuming actually is he's in the carpet
shampooer a Beijing hates that more than
anything so she always jumps up there
knives don't you pretty girl I know it's
terrible he's done now though the
monsters the monsters gone I can come
down if you want to okay she's not
taking any chances
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day and will continue to be odds
of a long time all right we're back for
the second half talking about Richard
Ramirez aka the Night Stalker
yeah we're actually start to talk about
the crimes now hopefully we can get you
laying the groundwork hopefully we can
get this done in an hour we'll see we'll
see it's a lot of material if you don't
go off on a lot of tangents although I
don't mind the tangents sometimes but
kiddies butt is moving the camera again
so she okay yeah she's like what Kat is
the cameraman she decided that she was
gonna like hang out behind my laptop and
your little butt is like scooting the
camera away
there okay so Richard Ramirez turns 18
in 1978 so he finally leaves Texas for
good and he goes to Los Angeles now at
this point like pretty much all he gave
a [ __ ] about was doing drugs listening
to heavy metal Satanism all his weird
like sexual fantasies etc etc so he goes
to stay with his brother Ruben like I
said who was the one that taught him all
the thievery and peeping-tom free and
whatnot so they lived together for a
while until most sources say they had an
argument about Rubens wife I'm assuming
it was something like Richard Ramirez
was like hey can I rape your wife and it
was like ya know and then that was
probably what the fight was about I'm
speculating
yeah and Ramirez is Satanism was a
self-styled Satanism yes it's not like
he came from you know Anton LaVey
well he did bring about Anton LaVey and
he seemed at first to like kind of want
to get into that like into the kind of
the more organized Satanism yeah but
then he decided that that that was for
[ __ ] to me rules well yeah like he
was gonna do his own thing and you know
I one thing about him is like
you know I can't really say I don't I
didn't know the dude but he did seem to
genuinely I mean he grew up Catholic so
he did genuinely seem to believe in
Satan as an actual being that was gonna
like protect him and [ __ ] he just seemed
to really believe that or at least he
seemed really adamant about saying that
right so his version of Satanism was
kind of like The Exorcist version of say
yes we're you know demon Devils are
protecting you yeah he seemed to
genuinely think that he was gonna get
away with all the [ __ ] that he was doing
because Satan was protecting him yeah
that's what okay
that's how it came across to me he
didn't seem like the brightest bulb
right I mean you know but I'm just
saying yeah so he did seem to genuinely
believe that so at this stage you know
him and his brother Ruben have an
argument about Rubens wife so he
eventually leaves he kind of graduates
from marijuana to cocaine which and PCP
which only kind of like Vassar Bates is
PCP already [ __ ] up tendencies so you
know that's not a happy thing for
anybody he's also starts breaking into
people's houses stealing you know to
support his drug habit
he doesn't really obviously doesn't have
any normal relationships with women it's
just like kind of all the prostitutes at
this stage according to some sources he
did one of his first known attacks on
another addict and he apparently tied
her up and raped her several times so
this was kind of like again another
turning point in his life like he seemed
to really enjoyed he enjoyed like having
power over someone else you know he
could do whatever he wanted to her and
she couldn't do anything about it so
that seemed to be something that made a
big impression on him now his sister
came to visit him his sister Ruth when
he
was in LA and he as I said he did
genuinely seem to believe in this whole
Satanism thing because he just tried to
explain to her that like the you know
this is like Who I am and it's like you
know this is how I express my thing
she said that he said something to the
effect of Satan represents what I feel
I'm not like other people
clearly I'm different I've got a trade
I'm a thief and a good one I'm not going
to any jail I'm protected she said
that's what he told her okay so like I
said he really did seem to believe
demons are watching out for ya that's
what Eaton really did seem to think okay
now his murder spree began now most
accounts of the Nightstalker crimes will
start in late June of 1984 but they
later in I don't believe it was until
2009 they discovered through DNA
evidence that he'd actually been
responsible for an earlier crime so his
actual first one happened on April 10th
1984 and this was the murder of a
nine-year-old girl her name was Mei lung
this was in the basement of a hotel that
he was living at and this was in San
Francisco in the Tenderloin district ok
you know what that means
hmm does those reports the hillside
strangler killings that I heard of as a
kid living out in California was not
Ramirez I was gone by then I was gone by
84 so no I was - I was wrong about that
yeah after all 84 85 it was only like
within a six-month period okay he did
like a rampage alright so I was wrong
about that hillside strangler must have
been just a hillside strangler yeah and
or maybe something like I said that was
- it was two guys but they were related
yeah but it must not have been Ramirez
Ramirez wasn't involved
no Bianchi did someone his own is I
could Amyris but I remember that was
going on in brass
70 yeah that was in 77 yeah this was mid
eighties but there seemed like there was
a lot of those hillside strangler
killing zone
kid well as I said thank Los Angeles in
the 70s and 80s there were at least that
I know of there were at least five
serial killers run around okay all right
and a lot of them had similar mos I
don't even think now it is they've
sorted I must have Ramirez confused with
somebody else because some of those
so-called hillside strangler killings I
remember as a kid hearing them up
hearing about him on the news wasn't
just the hillside Stranglers yeah it was
some other ones and mixed in there too
we should do a show about that yeah like
I said I brought him up a little bit
well him it was two guys you guys yeah
but both of them douchebags yeah I
brought it up a little bit on our show
about the alphabet killer
because for a time they thought maybe it
was the same it's the same dude but we
should do a whole show about that was
all I think like I said in LA in the 70s
and 80s yeah it was like a it was like a
[ __ ] serial killer it loved that it
was well it was kind of like remember
that show we did about [ __ ] London
Ontario mm-hmm where there was like five
or six serial killers they think like
running around and just what there was
just some kind of weird like really bad
like perfect storm of conditions that
made it so that there were all these
different killers running around same
thing happened kind of in Texas I guess
because the whole Texas killing fields
thing which you know it's like 30 35
women and girls turn up dead in this one
like they find all their bodies dumped
in this one area but they know it's at
least three killers probably more yeah
by 84 I was in Brazil already yes time I
passed my time at Cal yeah yeah cuz this
is like I said Ramirez's first crime
April 1984 and like I said they didn't
know that this was his first one until I
think 2009 because they backdated like
some DNA for this unsolved crime of this
little girl she was only nine
she'd been in San Francisco and she'd
been raped and beat her to death or beat
her and then stabbed her to death and
also hanged her body from a pipe as a
shot did yeah so so that was unsolved
for a long time but when they were doing
DNA later they found out that that was
really impressive
now because he was ashamed of it yeah he
seems like one of those people that yeah
kind of like Ted yeah when it was like a
little kid he don't wanna walk now
interestingly in 2016 though I heard
that they said that there was a second
male the second male's DNA at the scene
so him in one of his like dirtbag
relatives may uh might have done this
but they haven't like named who the
other one is or they don't know who the
other one is but they know for sure that
one of them was Ramirez so that was his
first known murder rape and murder
nine-year-old girl in San Francisco now
we're going to the more iconic
quote-unquote night stalker crimes first
of these occurred on June 28 1984 first
victim was 79 year old Jenny bin cow she
had an apartment in Glassell Park 79
yeah um she was actually somebody broke
into her house well somebody Richard
Ramirez broke into her house murdered
her while she was sleeping slit her
throat so severely that she was nearly
decapitated later they found like I said
they didn't identify Ramirez until later
but they found one of his fingerprints
on her window screen because he had
gotten in through an open window the
next one that they know I've happened on
st. Patrick's Day March 17th 1985 this
was 22 year old Maria Hernandez now she
had a house in Rosemead he came up to
her and shot her in the face with a 22
caliber handgun like after she pulled
into her garage but what she did was
when he pulled up the gun to shoot her
she put her hand up and had her keys in
it and the bullet ricocheted off the
keys yeah so she survived however
Richard Ramirez later went into the
house and killed her roommate Dale
Okazaki who was 34 that yeah the sad
thing like Dale heard the heard the
gunshot from outside of him shooting at
the roommate she ducked behind the
counter of the kitchen and then she kind
of peeked up to see what was going on
and
Jorge Ramirez shot her in the head so
killed her with one shot some weird [ __ ]
man these dudes doing this [ __ ] back in
the seventies I guarantee the size of
this one eighties yeah I have guarantee
I had to do with the that [ __ ]
unleaded gasoline you'd still have guys
doing it today but they're not it's like
I said it's less boys it's not the same
yeah it's not the same well and him for
sure because his poor mother was like
subjected all these like industrial
chemicals and stuff and all of his
siblings had like developmental
disorders birth defects and stuff like
that and they think it probe was
probably because of the chemicals that
she worked with and also maybe some of
the like [ __ ] nuclear fallout like
yeah Mexico there's a mutants fan pretty
much you know it's like it's The Hills
Have Eyes
yeah and it's actually surprising that
it happened I mean happening a lot in
the 70s and 80s but it's actually like
surprising these do happen more often
but I think that's that might be a
component like why it was more prevalent
back then blood poisoning their brains
are [ __ ] day you know yeah that you
don't hear about it as much nowadays
because you know we have better
environmental conditions I suppose yeah
so only um like an hour after the attack
where he um you know shot dil Okazaki
and shot Maria had Hernandez although
she survived he goes to Monterey Park
and he attacks a 30 year old named
Veronica you she's getting out of her
car and he just comes up to her and
shoots her and then runs off um she also
died you didn't take anything
no okay that's what he was just doing
devil yeah that's what I mean I mean
this guy it's like he didn't really now
a lot of the houses that he broke into
he'd he did steal a bunch of [ __ ] and
like fenced it later on so obviously
that was a motive to like that's how he
was making his living he would steal
jewelry and whatnot right but he just
got off on killing people and making
them suffer and that's just what he did
he just liked it I guess but you know
he's a [ __ ] yeah so
at this stage because there were three
attacks in one day two of the victims of
which had died and you know the one of
the witnesses had got a look at him so
they kind of described him they said he
had these like his teeth which is
something a lot of people have mentioned
he had like this really gross like
really rotting like why it's wide spaced
teeth so that was something that a lot
of the witnesses was a jack-o-lantern
bring up yet but he had like super gross
teeth also that he had like super super
girl's breath like it like smelled
really bad and then he had like these
big like weird like evil bulging type of
eyes dark curly hair that he looked kind
of Hispanic or whatever so he did there
was a description in the media at the
time they were calling him the valley
intruder or the walk-in killer that's
what they were calling him now a few
days after that I think it was only 10
days later this is March 27th 1985 he
breaks into it in 1984
like he had broken into it and just like
stolen a bunch of [ __ ] and then laughed
but this is like the same house this is
the Zara household so he breaks into
this house that's in Whittier it's about
2:00 in the morning he comes in he
immediately shoots um Vincent Cesare who
was 64 years old he just shoots him in
the head and kills him with his handgun
now the wife Maxine she was 44 years old
she is obviously woken up by the gunshot
and so Richard Ramirez starts beating
her up and asking where her stuff is
like worse the jewelry where's the money
all this other kind of [ __ ] now while
he's like looking around the house
Maxine knows I'm not sure if she knew at
this point that her husband was already
dead but she knew that her husband kept
a shotgun like under one of the bed so
she rolls under there while Richard
Ramirez is like [ __ ] around in the
house she rolls under there and gets it
and then she tries to shoot him but it
wasn't loaded yeah sadly keep your [ __ ]
loaded folks so yes so that just made
him mad so then he shot her three times
with the 22 caliber handgun that he had
then he got a carving knife out of the
kitchen stabbed her a bunch of times and
gouged her eyes out and either some
sources say he took them with him some
sources say he left them in her jewelry
box post where he put them in the
jewelry box and then took the jewelry
box with him it could arise out post
mortar or while she was alive I don't
know okay yeah and like I said another
one that criminal psychologist says
listened to in this documentary was like
that's something that like serial
killers with a particular type of
personality type do especially if they
had like this weird like paranoid type
of thing they will cut people's eyes out
because they don't like to see
themselves reflected in people's eyes
that they feel like people are watching
them so that's something that they would
do because I think Richard Ramirez did
that like more than once so yeah he
gouged her eyes out and took them with
him like in the jewelry box
all right so I'm looking at my notes and
it actually does say that the eyeballs
were cut out after she was dead okay
small mercy but I'm just saying so at
the scene police found a pair of
footprints and they had come from this
brand of sneakers called avea now that
would be like important later on because
that would help them like link up all
the other crimes so that was the only
like [ __ ] that they found they also
found some bullets at the scene that
were the same as some of the previous
attacks so they knew that this was
probably the same dude the next attack
happened May 14 1985 this also happened
in Monterey Park Richard Ramirez breaks
into the house of bill joy who was 66
years old and his wife Lillian who is 56
she is also disabled so he comes in and
bill is in the bedroom and bill actually
he has a gun and he goes for it but
Richard is faster than him and shoots
him in the face
now then after he shot him like he beat
him into like unconsciousness I don't
think he actually killed him outright he
died later but then after that he goes
into Lillian's room and put her in some
cuffs and then raped her this is a
disabled 56 year old man like I said
this guy was not I think he just picked
houses at random and just [ __ ] with
whoever was in there he would just take
all your [ __ ] if there was a woman in
there he would rape her if there was a
dude in there he would just shoot you in
the face yeah that's like how he
operated you shot him in the face too
well some of them he did some of them he
some of them he let live which now the
next one happened only like a week or
two later May 29th 1985 he has stolen a
car it was a Mercedes Benz then he just
randomly stops at the house of two
elderly women Mable Bell who was 83 and
her sister Florence Lang who was 81
Mable
Lawrence yeah yeah then you don't get
those names anymore not really although
if yours is a cool name I think what
really maples kind of a cool name too
that's old-school yeah so he breaks into
their house he finds a hammer in the
kitchen and then he goes to Florence and
bludgeoned her with the hammer then he
ties up Mabel and bludgeoned her as well
and then he took an electrical cord and
like shocked her with it also raped
Florence and then he stole Mabel's
lipstick and drew a pentagram on her
inner thigh and he drew pentagrams on
their bedroom walls because you know
Satan yeah Kasane yeah
now this the creepy thing about this was
that nobody found these two women for
two days and after two days they were
both still alive kitty yeah she keeps
moving she's kicking it yeah what are
you there for two days a lot they were
in there for two days alive and they
eventually did find them and they were
both still alive
although Mabel died of her injuries
later on but I believe that Florence
survived but yeah can you imagine they
were laying there for two [ __ ] days I
mean god that's horrible
alright so the day after that he takes
this stolen mercedes-benz he drives to
Burbank and he breaks into the house of
a 42 year old woman in Carroll Kyle now
at gunpoint he tells her now she has an
11 year old son who was also living in
the house he like tied them together
with handcuffs and starts like looking
through their house for valuables then
he tells Carol he's like where's all the
stuff and she didn't really know he then
anally rape sir and um yeah
he kept saying stuff like and again this
is like harkening back to what I said
about paranoid killers he kept saying
don't look at me don't look at me um any
threatened to cut her eyes out as well
which he had done before so I guess
was an empty threat so after that so yes
so he had raped her but he'd actually
didn't kill her
he actually took off like he took the
kid out of the closet and you know put
the two together with handcuffs but then
he took off hmm now
July 2nd 1985 he had stolen another car
this is a Toyota he went to Arcadia and
he picked another house at random and
this was the house of mary-louise cannon
who was 75 years old he breaks into her
house she was sleeping he bludgeoned her
with a lamp and then stabbed her with a
10-inch butcher knife from the kitchen
she was found dead at the scene
scumbag yeah yeah three days later yeah
he breaks into another house in Sierra
Madre bludgeoned 16 year-old Whitney
Bennett with a tire iron while she was
sleeping then he's looking around in the
kitchen for a knife he can't find one
and then so he tries to strangle her
with a telephone cord and this was kind
of weird but like he tries to strike
over the telephone cord and he sees like
kind of sparks coming out of it what and
that freaked him out because he thought
I don't know if you really thought this
but this is what he said he thought that
Jesus was intervening to save her and he
better get the [ __ ] out of there because
he was like on Satan's team yeah so he
thought oh well this barks come out of a
telephone cord yeah I don't believe that
I know he's lying I don't know I don't
know I'm just saying though he doesn't
have voltage going through there but she
lived oh that girl lived even though she
needed almost 500 stitches to fix her
scalp because he had like [ __ ] her up
so bad damn okay so the nether next one
happened July 7th 1985 which is only two
days later he breaks into the home of 61
year old Joyce Nelson in Monterey Park
she was asleep on the living-room couch
and he beat her to death by pretty much
just using his fists and kicking her
this was another scene where they found
the shoe print from his very distant
sneaker they found it imprinted into her
face so so the next ones he did to other
neighborhoods he goes back to Monterey
Park the next one was Sophie Dickman who
was 63 years old he assaulted and
handcuffed her at gunpoint attempted to
rape her and stole her jewelry and then
made her swear to Satan which was the
thing that he did in a lot of his later
crimes make him swear to Satan yeah what
that you wouldn't tell that you wouldn't
tell or is that you know I don't know I
don't know I'm not gonna attempt to get
into the mind right [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're thinkin July 20th 1985 he I
don't know if this was the same Toyota
that he sold before if this is a
different toy that you sold this is a
different stolen car so he's gonna not
stealing cars that [ __ ] too
he also bought a machete instead of
stealing it so at least he paid it for
the machete I guess yes is something
then he goes to Glendale he breaks into
the home of Lila needing and her husband
Maxon Lilly needing 66 and her husband
was 68 he busts into their bedroom and
starts hacking at them with the machete
then shoots them in the head with his 22
then act after they were dead he also
like kind of cut up their bodies with
the machete just for shits and giggles I
guess and then goes to their house stole
are their valuables [ __ ] and took off
now what was something so far what's
that he's been shooting all these people
in their houses with a 22 not a single
reported gunfire well not that I know of
you know why it's pretty quiet yeah yeah
I accidentally [ __ ] fired off a 380
in my house we had roommates at the time
they didn't even know when did that
happen cause backgrounds in Boston yeah
because it was a snow whoops I had a
damn I had as a Grendel 380 yeah yes
that company ended up becoming Caltech I
said I had a full magazine in there and
a [ __ ] 380 round chamber and put it
inside the box put it up on top of the
shelf
and accidentally dropped it when I took
my hand
that I actually pulled it back off and
hit the ground in that box and in the
carrying case and it wasn't that
particular pistol had problems I didn't
know but it it fired off accidental
discharge when it hit the ground and it
hits carpet it ya know that went right
over the top of top of my [ __ ] toe to
and hit my [ __ ] digital clock that
was on the ground and then embedded
itself into my futon when did it hit the
ground and just went crack and I saw a
piece of plastic flying and I said how
the hell'd that crack and I picked it up
or does it had fire fired but because it
was inside that plastic box with the
[ __ ] latches shut and acted like a
suppressor yeah it's silenced it yeah
but you said it 22 is it very loud 22 is
very loud okay a silenced or suppressed
9-millimeter puts out about as many
decibels as as an unsuppressed 22 so you
have those people [ __ ] paranoid about
silencers alright silencers really
aren't all that quiet they're really not
they're about as quiet as an
unsuppressed 22 yeah but you can hear
that you know I mean you know that shots
are fired but if you're in one house you
could shoot that place up and the house
next and the house said they'd wait they
wouldn't know well no of course not
especially if it was the middle of the
night yeah yeah you know when people
were sleeping
it's like it wouldn't be loud enough to
wake you up you could probably fire an
unsuppressed 9-millimeter into one house
and the house next door wouldn't hear it
it was you know if you were listening
for it you'd probably hear it yeah but
it's you're lying around you'd never
notice it well maybe well even if it
woke you up it would be one of those
things we're like if you woke up you're
like wait did I just hear something or
that I just dreamed I don't think it
would wake you up the fear in the house
next door yeah probably
if you were in that house you'd hear it
yeah you'd go what was that but if it
was a guy running it would be too late
cause he'd be running in you're like a
lot of these type of home invasion type
killers and I've written about a lot of
them in my books and stuff a lot of do
use 22s and maybe that's why maybe for
that reason yeah you could buy fire off
rounds inside of one house the house is
the adjacent houses wouldn't wouldn't
hear any well they wouldn't notice
anything like I said if they were
listening for it they my ability right
but who the [ __ ] would be looking for a
listen shops next door all right
I'd safe to say unless you live in a
really bad for me i'ma me on my personal
experience I'm going to tell you that
380 and 32 also about like is about like
22 380 is another one that a lot of them
means yeah 380 and 32 and 22 and 25
you can fire you can use that indoors
and and the adjacent houses won't really
notice it and I don't think adjacent
apartments would notice it yeah you were
in a building you don't really need a
suppressor just get a [ __ ] smaller
cart well and I feel like the [ __ ] that
Ramirez was doing like he would break
into your house in the middle of the
night like 2:00 3:00 4:00 in the morning
wake you up yeah and he'd be sleeping
and so he'd probably just like put the
gun right up to your [ __ ] head and
just like pop you right in the head and
like no one would hear that yeah I
wouldn't think well when you say
silencer suppressor there's no such
thing as a silencer it's actually called
a suppressor okay well yeah it's not
silenced I've heard it no you know it's
quieter but it's not there's Hollywood
silence that's what they're telling you
in the movies you know I mean and a
full-size pistol like a 9-millimeter is
never Hollywood silent the only thing
that's gonna get silent kind of like
that is you take it like a suppressed 22
yeah a suppressed 22 kind of sounds like
like a BB gun yeah but you don't really
need it because you know yeah it's quite
showing you that an unseen race anyways
but not enough to like the engine right
and I'm suppressed 22 is about as
effective it's not like everybody in the
street be like hey that's a gunshot yeah
there's a gunshot no no you're dealing
with rifles yeah but not these small
pistol cartridges well yeah and I think
as far as I know everybody the he was
shot that was shot in the Nightstalker
crimes it was a shot with a 22
are they maybe a 25 in a couple of them
not that loud yeah so all of the stuff
that he had stolen from the needing pow
he fenced it and then he drives to Sun
Valley I don't know if this was the same
day or the same night whatever so it's
about like it's 4:15 in the morning then
he breaks into another house and this
house is channa rank of a knife who I
think he was either from Thailand or
Taiwan I can't remember it was him and
his wife his wife's name was some kid
now the dude Chan wrong was sleeping so
Richard Ramirez shot him in the head
with the 25 then he takes the wife and
rapes and sodomized Azhar they also had
an eight-year-old son in the house who
he tied up and then he takes the wife
after he had raped and sodomized her any
drugs around the house like looking for
any money or valuables or anything like
that which he took everything that she
pointed out he also asked her to swear
to Satan that she wasn't hiding anything
from him you better live yeah she looked
like I said he he would do that like a
lot of the women lived
I don't think hardly any of the men did
right cuz he would just usually shoot
them while they were sleeping and then
take the wives and rook and what did it
do whatever
so the next one happened August 6 1985
this was in Northridge he breaks into
the house of Kristen Virginia Peterson
Virginia was 27 years old he like snuck
into her bedroom she woke up and she was
like you know frightened he shot her in
the face with the 25 he then shot her
husband Kris in the forehead and started
to run away but Kris like fought back
against him and he got shot two more
times but actually both of them survived
yeah so like I said some of these people
are surviving that's why they have like
such a good description of him yeah 25
isn't is notoriously kind of like anemic
it was it was a replacement it was John
Moses Browning replacement for 22
long-rifle
yeah used in small pistols pocket
pistols because it was a centerfire
cartridge instead of rimfire and you
know it was it was it was a good
smokeless cartridge but out of a real
short barrel you know to me all all your
twenty fives are pocket pistols they're
very small and there's not enough barrel
there to get that thing really singing
and it's just notorious of people
surviving head shots of 25
well actually 22 has a better track
record than 25 but I think that's
because a lot of 22s have longer barrels
I think it was about yeah 22s tend to be
bigger than 25 oh yeah on average you
might be talking about three or four
inch barrel like I said of all the
crimes that I read about thank you is
pretty much the most common yeah you
even own the automatics you do among
among killers don't shoot their victims
yeah the power level is actually the
same the only the only real difference
is the fact that 22 is rimfire which is
an 1800s design you know I mean there's
no primer in the center of it it's more
some more apt to get an oil
contamination but 22s tend to have
longer barrels yeah so you talk about
3/4 inch barrel some more accuracy no
more velocity yeah because it's you know
the barrels the bullets in the barrel
longer accelerating longer but 25 tend
to be little bitty pocket pistols and
once the rounds chamber you're talking
about not even an inch of barrel so the
same power level but that's barrel so
it's not under it's not being
accelerated as it's not under the same
rate of acceleration you know it's not
in the barrel very long right so lower
velocity on average but it's just funny
cuz you hear about yeah he killed her
with a 22 to the head you know but 25
shouting three times the 25 they lived
technically it's the same power level
but the barrel links well like I said
these these to this couple were both
shot I mean I think I believe that uh
Chris Peterson was shot three times in
the head and still survived
yeah and Virginia was
survived at least one shot in the head
I've owned all these guns you know 25s
and stuff a little Titan 25 Titan Titan
Tiger 25 s and just saw the saw that
caliber do weird [ __ ] you know what I
mean you have any distance you know 15
feet 15 20 feet you hit anything solid
with it you can hear point 25 bullet
bounced off of it you know yeah but you
know 22s tend to have a couple more
inches of barrel even 32 is like that 32
if he doesn't have any barrel length you
just can't get it up to enough speed you
know even though I love 32 I had a Colt
pocket hammerless 32 colt oh three
pocket hammerless nice little pistol
Soviets kind of turned it into a Tokarev
9-millimeter but I'm going on track
although everybody says in it in the
commended I like it when you talk about
guns we have so we have some collectors
in the audience they like it I start
going down that way but 32 was the
old-fashioned 9-millimeter really that
was the original automatic pistol
cartridge very popular and it's just
that you know that was very early
nineteen hundreds and by the time the
80s just rolling around you know pocket
pistol calibers is 25 little short
barrels you know yeah I'm glad that he
had those weak guns like oh yeah he did
enough [ __ ] damage yeah nowadays you
know some of the people did live
although I'm not sure I'd want to live
after all the [ __ ] that yeah but all
those guns are gone they're they're kind
of vanishing from the market nowadays
you have a little micro 9 millimeters
they're very effective yeah very
effective but then again we don't have
psychos like this thrown around even now
even though this is a huge country for
you foreigners out there these guys were
from a certain era they just they're
just not around I mean there's always
psychos in every era but I don't like
doing this it's not quite the same not
quite the same I feel like 60s 70s early
80s up until about 1987 nice
I feel like that was kind of like the
heyday most of America's gone to
violence is [ __ ] gang-related yeah
really there aren't any innocent people
involved in it it's different gangs well
you get mass shooters but that's
actually a small percentage it's a small
percentage I mean an anomaly
and every eight knows by putting those
on television well like I said I always
feel like it's kind of like and and I
was gonna like mention this to you but I
kind of feel like that might have been
some of the problems too with Richard
Ramirez calm like the Night Stalker it's
like don't give them cool nicknames yeah
don't do that this was the era of serial
killers the era of [ __ ] leaded
gasoline it just like it plays into
their holes yeah it plays into their
whole like fantasy scenario of like I'm
such a badass
it was the pre-internet era where guys
like this kid [ __ ] fantasize about a
world that didn't exist and they
couldn't hear about what people said
about them yeah yeah I mean I just
they're just not like that
these guys just don't happen it's like
they used to well like I said every now
that culture has changed a lot like I
said it's for the better I think that's
like cuz this [ __ ] doesn't I mean they
ran into a couple one a couple years
backwards guy was chained and women up
in his damn sheds and kill and I'm you
know and he was one of these but they're
caught earlier yeah and they don't quite
get the same kind of coverage the things
I do feel like they've kind of like
caught on to that let's not make them
like celebrities yeah type of thing you
just create more of them just make them
seem like a pathetic scumbag that's what
they are that's what you need to do
because that's what they are that's the
same with school shooters yeah this [ __ ]
you just make them look like a pathetic
scumbag no one will want to do that yeah
yours so after the attack um on the
Petersons which happened August 6 1985
two days later there was another one
Ramirez stole a car he drove it to
Diamond Bar and he chooses another house
at random this was the house of Sakina
Iowa and her husband Elias
Sakina was 27 her husband was 31 about
2:30 3:00 a.m. he breaks into the house
he shoots the husband
the head for the 25 while he was
sleeping so he was instantly dead then
he handcuffed
Sakina and beat her up asking her where
all the money was where the jewelry was
then again raped and sodomized her and
again made her swear on Satan that she
wasn't gonna scream that she was gonna
do what he said blah blah blah imagine
the cops are profiling the [ __ ] out of
this guy
oh is the guy who's making you swear to
Satan yeah we know that one right yeah
now this couple also had a three year
old kid who walked into the room during
this whole attack and then Ramirez ties
up the three year old and then continues
raping the moms so in front of the three
year old I'm assuming which that's
[ __ ] up yeah but the mom and the kid
both lived you know after Ramirez left
she untied the son they went to the
neighbors for help and they lived but
they're you know the husband was done
now since at this stage the media was
kind of going crazy like they knew that
that was the same dude because of like
you know the ballistics evidence and
like the shoe prints and stuff so they
knew this was probably the same dude
that was perpetrating all these crimes
and the Greater Los Angeles area so
there was a lot of media coverage about
the crimes so Ramirez decides he's gonna
like lay low for a while or kind of like
go for a little vacation or whatever the
[ __ ] he was gonna do Joe on his stolen
millions yes so 100 stolen hundreds yeah
so he goes to San Francisco now a little
a few days later it was I think it was
August 18th which was ten days after his
former attack he goes into a house in
San Francisco which was the house of
Peter and Barbara Pan Peter Pan which so
case before that was his name but I know
yeah that was his name he was 66 years
old he was again was sleeping her
marriage shoots him in the head with the
25 and kills him he then beats and rapes
Barbara who was 62 years old and then
shot her in the head and left her for
dead
he also took lipstick and wrote he drew
a pentagram and he wrote Jack the knife
on the bedroom wall because clearly
trying to be cool and [ __ ] like the edge
Lordan that's what I mean this is like
the very definition she lived I don't
know actually is left for dead so I
thought yeah I think she did live
actually but the husband died okay so
all right now at this stage because this
crime had happened in San Francisco and
like I said in the seventies and
eighties I think the reason the why I
love serial killers from this era were
not caught quicker was because there was
a lot of like cooperation between
different police departments in
different cities and we didn't have the
internet and you know they weren't
really like they were kind of like hey
this is our case hey this is our case
and there was always any cooperate it
was a lot of bitchery going on you know
so I think that really like impeded the
kind of the investigation
now the mayor of San Francisco at the
time kind of came as she did a press
conference and she told the press that
the murderer award these particular type
of shoes he's a via sneakers and stuff
and the police were freaking out because
they're like hey don't tell me don't
tell him that because now he's gonna
he's watching it and he's gonna and
that's exactly what happened because
Richard Ramirez had been watching the
news and he saw that oh they know what
kind of shoes I have on so he took those
sneakers and he threw them off the
Golden Gate Bridge and he also threw off
the gun that he'd been using so there
was that whole thing because they were
very distinctive like I said these
sneakers they found out later this was
the only pair that had been sold in the
Los Angeles area because they were size
11 and a half he had black big giant
feet yeah so you know so they would have
you know they were identified in moravia
so the next crime like after that
happened the next crime occurred August
24th 1985 so he goes to Mission Viejo
which is 75 miles or 76 miles south of
Los Angeles he's out of there yeah he's
stolen another car yeah yeah my mother
actually
used to ride horses out missin train
horses out in Mission Viejo
there's a lot of cool barns out there
and ranches there's a pretty Drive yeah
yeah listen it all seventies musics in
the car what I'm going down there Shogun
warriors with me oh yeah yeah one of
those are up there listen like some 70s
oh yeah there's some [ __ ] hell yeah oh I
can imagine it right now yeah it's all
kinds of cool [ __ ] yeah so he drives
down there he picks a house at random
again this is the house of James Romero
jr. now this family had just come back
from a vacation now it so happens that
James Romero's son who was 13 years old
James remar the third he heard Richard
Ramirez walking around outside the house
because he was still awake so he's like
oh there must be a burglar outside so he
goes to wake his parents up so Richard
Ramirez is like well I'm gonna get the
[ __ ] out of here but this 13 year old
kid who's a [ __ ] hero he's like that
sounds like a [ __ ] prowler so he runs
and he sees the car which was you know
so he so he takes down it's like an
orange Toyota and he takes down I don't
think he got the whole plate but I think
he just got like the first three numbers
of the second three numbers but it got
like a partial plate so like I said this
thirteen-year-old kid he's a [ __ ]
hero so he not only like chased the guy
away because he woke up but he also like
got some information about it so after
this happened Ramirez was obviously kind
of pissed off because that had been like
you know that whole mission was aborted
so he goes and breaks into another house
this happened to be the house of Bill
carne to his thirty years old and his
fiancee
Inez Erikson who was 29 he breaks in
through the back door goes into the
bedroom and he wakes bill up by cocking
his handgun he shoots bill three times
in the head
then he tells is he was still alive and
her [ __ ] fiance is dead right beside
her he says I'm the night stalker swear
your love to Satan blah-dee-blah
he beats her up you know just with his
hands and and he ties her up with
neckties that he's taken out of the
closet he takes all the [ __ ] out of
their house jewelry money whatever then
he takes Inez to another room he directs
her another bedroom rapes and sodomized
her and then he's like okay well do you
have any more money in the house do you
have any more jewelry in the house she
said no will swear to Satan that there's
not any more in there she's like okay
fine now she actually did live and I
think actually her fiancee ended up
living - even though he got shot twice
in the head and they didn't think he was
gonna make it but he actually did an
oblivion now Inez was actually able to
give a really good description although
it's weird because I've seen looks
exactly like Lou Reed which is good
Ramirez doesn't look much like Lou Reed
but I could see what they were going for
right but as soon as I saw the sketch I
was like that like [ __ ]
I mean I've heard Lee Reed was like an
epic douche I've heard that like I love
Lee Read's music but as a person I
provide news but he wasn't so cool but
but the the sketch really didn't look
like Lou Reed is right Los Angeles like
murdering people
damn yeah so she actually gave them a
description and I think that that's
where that iconic kind of composite
sketch came from and they actually got
um you know the cast of the footprint
and [ __ ] like that so at this stage they
were actually able to get a single
fingerprint off the rear view mirror of
the car that he had stolen normally he
wore gloves so they didn't have
fingerprints or he would wipe the cars
clean he was usually like he wasn't I
mean he was mad he was stupid but he
wasn't that stupid like he did know to
like wear clothes
wipe to like wear gloves and wipe down
the cars and stuff but apparently he
missed this one because what I've heard
it was super hot that night he took off
his gloves and he didn't realize when he
had justed the mirror without putting
his gloves back on so they did actually
get a single
print from a rear view mirror of the car
that he had stolen
now this print was later used to
identify him as Richard Ramirez because
he had a prior record they knew he was
from Texas he was at this stage 25 years
old he had nothing major like the
arrests it was mostly like drug stuff
like traffic stops that kind of crap but
he still had a record so they did pair
him so they knew who it was now you know
what I mean so that's kind of like a big
deal so at this stage there they had a
mugshot of him where he had been
arrested in December of 1984 from like a
car theft that he had done so they
released it to the press and they had a
whole press conference and everything
that the cop said we know who you are
now and we're coming after your stupid
ass mm-hmm now it's weird because like I
said Ramirez keep in mind that like this
whole murder spree I mean it only
happened over a period of like six
months it this wasn't like a super long
time like I said it wasn't a original
Nightstalker situation was like years
and years but it was a pretty brief time
period so Ramirez is still thinking that
they don't know who he is now in August
30th of 1985 he actually got on a
Greyhound bus and he was going to Tucson
Arizona to visit his brother now at this
stage he was not aware that the police
had twigged to who he was and had put
his stupid ass face all over every
[ __ ] piece of media ever so he goes
to Tucson and I guess his brother is at
home or he's like on vacation or
whatever so Richard Ramirez hops on a
bus to come back to Los Angeles now the
cops had staked out the bus stations I
mean among other places where they
figured he was trying to leave town or
whatever they staked out the bus
stations thinking that he was going to
be leaving Los Angeles but then they
actually like caught him when he was
coming back to Los Angeles from Tucson
because he's like walking in the bus
station not knowing that his [ __ ]
picture is all over
every [ __ ] newspaper in the news and
everything so he comes back on August
31st he comes striding into the [ __ ]
Greyhound bus station in Los Angeles and
he goes into like he like the cops kind
of cm or like some people see him and
you know there's a lot of like Mexican
American like community around this you
know around this area and [ __ ] like that
and one woman recognized image she
pointed right Emma she said El Matador
yeah the killer yeah so they knew who it
was so everybody's like oh [ __ ] they
knew exactly who that [ __ ] was
so he starts running down the street and
everybody starts running I remember this
part of the story yeah yeah he's running
down the street and everybody's chased
him yeah all of you heroes yeah so he
starts running - he runs across the
Santa Ana freeway he tries to carjack a
woman like a bunch of other people or
chase him they're like oh no that's not
gonna happen he starts like hopping over
fences and [ __ ] like that he tries to
carjack like two other people and then
it like a bunch of people like he tries
to carjack this woman I think his
husband or her husband like comes at a
thing with a [ __ ] iron bar and like
starts to [ __ ] hit him in the head
with it
and he runs off and eventually like this
whole like [ __ ] mob of people just
like descend I'm start beating the
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like I said rightly so
register right righteous justice yeah so
then the cops had to come save his [ __ ]
ass from all these people because some
of the people in the crowd like I said
understand it's Ronnie were like where's
my gun where's my gun bring my company
shoot I can remember this I knew exactly
who them and the cops that arrest him
said that he was basically like save me
save me to the cops figures yeah yeah
yeah I remember that
but yeah so this mob [ __ ] tracked his
ass down and like I said they knew is
that and they said there was like the
guy that read the book of it like the
biography about him stuff said like
everybody's head was like Elm add to the
world that some of they were just like
chasing him down the [ __ ] Street yes
yeah that's that's pretty awesome I have
to say so finally they arrested this
[ __ ] douche
so his trial begins July of 1988 how
much time we have left let's see we are
at 3500 36 we go that yeah so his trial
begins in July of 1988 so this [ __ ]
dork like comes into the [ __ ] booth
he's I've got all the black clothes on
his black sunglasses look at all like
Mick Jagger whatever it's [ __ ] stupid
feather hair why not he's coming over
this [ __ ] pentagram drawing on his
hand like hail see he's doing this from
the jailhouse yeah it's like whatever in
it yet do you sound like Hale saying bah
bah bah I remember they hated the
mirrored sunglasses actually just like
could you be any more annoying yeah so
he was apparently like plotting to kill
the prosecutor like he was trying to
like set that whole thing up how was he
gonna do that he was but he was trying
to no he was trying to look he was
trying to do by prosaic means he was
trying to like smuggle a gun into the
courtroom okay so they actually had to
install a metal detector which you know
they didn't have back then now they have
metal detectors and all the courtrooms
but they didn't back then but they did
it in this case because he had said that
he had been heard saying that he was
gonna do that [ __ ] and also they had to
do like searches of everybody coming in
there um
now one interesting thing that happened
during the trial ball interesting in a
bad way was that less than a month after
the trial started the trial had to be
stopped for a couple of days because one
of the jurors whose name was Phil a
Singletary she didn't show up one day
and they wondered where she was and they
found her shot dead in her apartment now
at first they thought I mean because
Ramirez was in custody but they thought
that maybe he had like an accomplice out
there yeah like had an accomplice like
pull that [ __ ] but then it turned out
later that her boyfriend had done it
because he ended up committing suicide
later with the same gun okay and then
he's like he admitted like in the
suicide note that he had done it but
still like there was still that kind of
lingering dude
yeah yeah because like the the person
that had to come in like as an alternate
for that poor dead woman was like [ __ ]
this I don't wanna [ __ ] be on this
jury because they you know they thought
that Ramirez was gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] knock
it off yeah well because he had
threatened to do that he had threatened
to like I'm gonna bring in a gun I'm
gonna shoot the process he's in custody
though it's hard to it's hard to do that
right but you know it's a you have to
think that like he had been like
terrorizing the community for half a
year at this point everyone was [ __ ]
terrified of fancy he had hit a rep
right yeah so I I don't blame people at
all for thinking yeah he's gonna kill my
my eyes I don't want to be on that
[ __ ] jury no [ __ ] way
and really this is in the depths of the
satanic panic because they're right even
wise then there was a lot of that
chairman have been a lot of people that
actually believe that maybe this was
about Satan exactly and that yeah that
was like part of the whole [ __ ] just
oh [ __ ] knocking people laughing yeah
they may have thought he had like
[ __ ] magical powers oh right yeah so
you have to like kinda take that into
consideration also so yeah as you know
as much as he try to be all slick and
everything and like he would do [ __ ]
like you know when when there would be
like witnesses up on the stand and
they'd be like crying and stuff like you
do because it's like you know their
[ __ ] relatives got murder in the best
fashion and he'd be over there being on
like flipping through like crime-scene
photos like oh look at that how funny
and blah blah and so you know like I
mean this kind of person he's just like
[ __ ] pisses me off so much but yeah
so the jury was not having it um so he
gets convicted of all charges
that he was accused of 13 counts of
murder five counts of attempted murder
11 sexual assaults 14 burglaries and
really this is this is just the
beginning of Ramirez's story because he
lives a long time IV still but might be
alive as an inmate no he's dead he's
dead now and he did bunch of [ __ ]
happened well you know he got married
reappear in the in in the media it's
just you know this guy's wouldn't go
away as much as we wanted it to he was
yeah so he was uh Burton to Christianity
and turnover and I don't know if he did
that but he did that but um yeah so he
was convicted of the myriad charges
against him so November of 1989
sentenced to death in California's gas
chamber now after they were taking him
out and there's a very famous video if
you want to look at it on YouTube it's
all over the place they're leading him
out to the little van or whatever and he
says big deal death always went with the
territory see in Disneyland yes it was
very famous quote that he said after
they sentence him to death now you went
to San Quentin on death row he said that
he wasn't afraid of dying because he
believed that he would have an honored
place in Satan's Kingdom along with Jack
the Ripper and Ted Bundy and all those
sterling examples of humanity so you
know now according to one source I read
the trial cost the state of California
1.8 million dollars yeah which in 2018
dollars is three point six four million
dollars which at the time was the most
expensive trial ever undertaken until
the OJ Simpson trial now famously as you
said he got married in prison now this
is another thing that I do not [ __ ]
understand okay it's like I'm fascinated
with true crime and all this kind of
crap but this kind of chick here oh yeah
this she's a serial killer kruky so what
he had a bunch of them yeah and that was
like creepy like he shows up in court
like with all his [ __ ] like black
like look how Mick Jagger and I'm so
badass and whatnot and he had like a lot
of chicks like fell for that they must
have like super low self-esteem or
really bad he evidently got whole
garbage bag clothes he did they said
they got he got all kind of like fan
mail and [ __ ] oh he's so charismatic and
stuff even though I don't know whatever
so it was pre-internet I'm not saying
it's as bad as a serial killer but yeah
they're [ __ ] up that's that's pretty
[ __ ] up oh I can fix him that's what
they're thinking that's exactly what it
is I think that's exactly what it is but
because it's oh he'll kill everybody or
doing some but he'll be nice to me I'll
be the only
special yeah that's exactly what it's
just it's more a narcissism thing like
they want to feel like special like the
bad boy you're the only one that they're
nice to I'd kind of feel like that might
be where that's coming from so yeah he
all these fans and stuff like that but
in 1985 this one woman named Doreen Loy
she was 25 years old at the time and she
started writing to him now she wasn't um
she had a job and [ __ ] she wasn't like a
complete loser she was like a pretty
decent looking woman like I started a
documentary and she looked kind of like
me but you know she probably looked good
but she was 25 um you know she didn't
age all that well but you know she
probably look up and she was younger she
looked like she had looked good when she
was a kid but so she starts writing him
a bunch of letters she was like a
magazine editor I believe so she like
thought he was just the sexiest [ __ ]
alive and he was like so charismatic at
all
yeah like yourself [ __ ] wrapping
everything yeah and thought that he was
being treated unfairly which they're so
they're so median okay so mean to
Richard what the [ __ ] yeah
so she says she kept writing to him and
visiting him and stuff like that in 1988
he proposed to her and in 1996 they got
married in the prison now she said for
many years that when he got executed
because he was on death row remember
that she was gonna commit suicide too
because that's how devoted she was
that's not how that [ __ ] works out that
it turned out that even though that was
kind of a big deal at the time and like
this isn't super well-known I had to
like kind of dig down a little bit but
apparently what ended up happening was
that she started like after she found
out certain things about him which I'll
get into a minute but she started like
kind of being like ya know and she
started kind of like backing away like a
normal person would um and they
eventually split up so they were not
still married like when he died um it
took her a while to realize it wasn't a
good man like weird
he's a serial killer that's like the
biggest red flag that's a red flag like
the size of [ __ ] he's not me man I
thought he was some speculation is that
when they like in 2009 when DNA
determined that he had killed that nine
year old girl and that was his earliest
crime because that changed every because
like I said oh well a nine year old
that's different than like kill a bunch
of random adults yeah it's fine yeah
yeah yeah all the rapes that really
changed that was like the line in the
sand and I guess I don't know that's
what this I don't know I don't know if
that's was 13 other people yeah [ __ ]
that that's all yeah they were grownups
yeah well one of them was 16 but you
know whatever she's a grown-up it's like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I don't know
if that's why but that was some of the
speculation that that's kind of when she
started being like backing away slowly
yeah um it was also about this time that
he was diagnosed with hepatitis C Oh
and people are like maybe she was afraid
that she would contract it yeah so their
biological visits I suppose you know why
would he get it cuz your death row they
didn't get conjugal business you want to
smell that damn breath God Jack
O'Lantern teeth but yeah so it'd just be
craziness I guess well some of them are
for sure this one was but yeah it's like
so they'd say they don't know why but
she did eventually start like distancing
herself and she did actually eventually
split with him she didn't kill herself
when he died or nothing like that um yes
so he obviously you're on death row you
tried to do a bunch of Appeals and stuff
like that every single failed you know
as they would because he didn't deny
doing anything he didn't have any
remorse but he's like yeah I did that
[ __ ] whatever it was super cool so you
know no one is ever gonna feel sorry for
your stupid ass in that [ __ ] case now
contrary to popular belief Richard
Ramirez was even though he was on death
row he was not executed he actually died
of a disease he died of complications
from hepatitis C in 2013 he was 53 years
old
so it had to do with hepatitis C and all
the drug use and [ __ ] like that so it
caught up with this stupid-ass yeah I
thought they'd changed I thought they
changed his sentence didn't he get no
they didn't say he was nobody she was on
death row for 23 years um they just
hadn't got around to it yet because like
I said because of all the appeals and
stuff had been very slow but he actually
ended up dying of complications from
hepatitis C before they could do the
death go so he was no no wait he died of
natural causes
you know way escape justice he did yeah
he was in he was on death row I mean he
was on death row and hopefully I don't
know how painful or you know how much
suffering is engendered by hepatitis C
but hopefully it's a lot I don't think
it's much in this case he's get sick I
think but yeah that's what he died of
I mean he was 53 years old so he still
didn't live that long no right well I'm
right Lisa right so yeah okay that's
yeah chronic liver liver failure I think
was the cause of death that they put on
us that certificate yeah pretty much
and like I said I don't really know what
happened to his quote/unquote ex-wife
she kind of like dropped off the face of
the earth after she was just kind of
like oh he's a serial killer that
actually like raped and killed like yeah
kids and chamcha but they did some weird
yes yes how much human but they did some
weird-ass [ __ ] like look he's got he's
getting liver failure from his hepatitis
let's execute him now and they're like
no he's not healthy enough for the
execution that's that's probably why the
reason that's probably anyway he's not
healthy you know it's not wasting
electricity yeah he's not healthy enough
for the exit I guess it's gas chamber
let's not let's not waste the gas yeah
that's probably exactly what they
thought he'll just die of natural causes
a little while it's just put him in his
[ __ ] Talon let him [ __ ]
incidentally and I didn't know this but
you know the whole situation where
serial killers and [ __ ] like that will
get all these like [ __ ] groupies and
stuff there's a word for that it's
called hybristophilia first ofili am i
pronouncing that right Jamie but yeah
that's like an actual thing where it's
like these women
groupie killers yeah they're like
sexually aroused by criminals or like
serial killer
like we'll write them letters and want
to marry them and stuff yeah what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you chicks I don't
know you're making the whole gender look
bad come on you did represent those
kernels are loving it though well yeah
because they're getting something out of
it didn't give a [ __ ] about there's
someone for everyone Jenny that's not
always a good thing in this case but
really wasn't it
like I said I'm sure this woman had
other problems so I don't want to show
her too much but [ __ ] helmet is like
he kills all these people like he breaks
into people's houses shoots dudes in the
head yeah rapes well then rapes the wind
sometimes kills them as well like time's
up little kids and beats him up and [ __ ]
like that and that was all fine but then
you find out either a that he raped and
killed a nine-year-old girl or be that
he had you know hepatitis C or C both of
the above and then that was like the
breaking point yeah it took that she
crazy crazy we knew to talk shut it down
Jenny all right so I don't want to give
any more [ __ ] publicity or whatever
but you know in case you alright so
hopefully you guys have enjoyed this
[ __ ] hopefully you guys have got my
germs over the Internet cuz I'm just my
throat assistant right now yeah I'll be
alright though mm-hm
alcohol is helping yeah well that one
was strong yeah yeah I feel a little bit
better but my throat started to get
serious cuz I'm talking like cough
medicine
yeah yeah well what do you think think
that's about the same thing that's why I
figure it's cheaper and more fun alright
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
latest show about Richard Ramirez aka
the Night Stalker aka the [ __ ]
douchebag [ __ ] satanic douchebag of
the world so you know who's somehow got
somebody got somebody to marry him I
don't know how that happened but yeah so
alright and uh as always remember if you
liked the show like share subscribe on
all your social media if you would like
to financially support the show we would
love you forever and we would
very much go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little button in the
sidebar that goes to a PayPal account
and you can give a one-time donation if
you would like to do that remember our
last movie retrospective if you didn't
see it was stirrup Echo's from 1999 one
of my favorite like forgotten movies
from the 1990s so go check it out if you
have an array
remember our regular shows come out
every Tuesday and our movie
retrospectives every Friday 13 o'clock
matinee three new movies in the theater
that I've said every Sunday if you're a
patreon patron on patreon you get to see
all of the videos a day before everyone
else so you know you get to be special
in [ __ ] so it might be end of that I
don't know and that will do it for
episode 149 we will see you next time
for a big hundred fiftieth episode I
don't even know we're gonna do with it
yet but we'll see this may be something
exciting
maybe not so we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]